here for more reaction is GOP
Presidential candidate vi ramaswami v
okay so we need deprogramming I've been
across the country on a campaign with
the former president I've met millions
of people you know hardworking people
I've seen them at rallies teachers
people who love this country that are
part of the so-called Maga movement tell
me about some of the people that you've
met on the campaign trail that need to
be deprogrammed as was suggested by
Hillary
Clinton so the fact of the matter is I'm
here meeting in between town halls in
Northern New Hampshire and I can tell
you people don't need deprogramming what
we need is a Revival in this country
where everyday citizens who have been
villainized are able to speak their
minds openly what I see when I travel
the country Kaye is the biggest
indictment of our nation's health is
that people don't feel free to say in
public what they actually feel in
private and once we're all doing that
once again we might not agree on
everything but we're going to realize
that most of us in this country
so-called extremist or not share our
national values in common but I think
it's folks like Hillary Clinton who get
in the way with this cultural threat of
fear that has created this new epidemic
of fear in our country and that has to
stop and it's going to end on my watch V
so I hear Hillary Clinton talk about
deprogramming and I thought to myself
you know what happened to my neighbors
not my enemy you I'm friends with
Democrats who we all Americans you know
what happened to that and what a stark
contrast and this comes on the day after
by the way your car was hit I as I
understand you were on with my colleague
Jesse Waters last night talking about
that but what a STK contrast from
Hillary Clinton than this moment you had
today in New Hampshire let's play
it why I let the gentleman outside and
he seems like he really wants to come on
we'll carry your water for you oh than
come on app there you go yeah hi Mike
come on in hey Gabe join us what year
are you I'm a sophomore you're sophomore
yeah I've been I've been outside of
rooms I've tried to get into before
that's been frustrating you brought the
protester in and you even carried his
water I don't think Hillary Clinton
would carry the water of a Maga
supporter I'm just
guessing well you know the reality is we
don't all have to agree with one another
but I don't think that young man needed
to be reprogrammed he needed to be heard
actually that's why he was outside the
event he was making a lot of noise he
wanted to be heard I say why is he on
the outside when I was a young person
there were probably rooms I wanted to
get into that I wasn't in either even
though he was holding signs they said
they didn't let him in I went outside
and brought him in myself and you know
what that's how Kaylee we're going to
recover our country is that we have to
revive Free Speech you're free to speak
your mind as long as I get to in return
and so does that young man that is the
American way and I want to say this too
Kaylee that is an extreme idea you want
to talk about magga extremists well you
know what our country is founded on
Extreme ideals free speech is an extreme
ideal self-governance is an extreme
ideal because for most of human history
including in Old World Europe it was
done the other way we fought an American
Revolution to defend yes extreme ideals
but that's what unites us As Americans
across our diversity that is what makes
America great that is what makes America
itself and so I think we should stop
this culture of apologizing for the
nature of those radical revolutionary
ideas those radical ideals are part of
our American identity and the top of the
list is free speech and open debate
that's in the First Amendment for a
reason and we need to keep that at the
Forefront of our national culture so I'm
doing my part as I travel college
campuses across this country my rule of
thumb is if you're protesting you get
the mic as long as you get to hear my
response in return and we're going to
lead by example what a welcome contrast
to the former Secretary of State thank
goodness she was never a president VI
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analyses
you will not get it anywhere
else